tablet i got to tell you i listened to
your album last night it is absolutely
brilliant uh epic high
is here has his vibe to it it is
powerful so congratulations to you i
applaud it
i was listening to the car with driving
with my husband because what is this i'm
like it is a new album that is
absolutely amazing from epic high
i know a lot of your your plans diminish
because of code for a lot of people but
this
album was born uh what does it mean for
you to be able to put music out there
for your fans to enjoy yeah like um
i think this is the first time where
fans all over the world
um and i felt the exact same emotions
over the last
year or so we all were in
you know mega chaos
confusion uh a lot of anxiety as well so
it felt like a good time for us to
release new music um and speak to
everyone that is feeling the same thing
and hopefully bring a little bit of
light to the situation i guess
and unfortunately music is the only way
i can do that
i wish there was more i could do but
music is powerful though it brings so
many different emotions and
listening to your song lesson zero the
first one off the album
totally gave me eminem vibes first of
all um thank you
it's it's so good but how would you you
talked about this
being able to speak to your fans but how
would you describe the emotions of this
album because
you kind of go on a roller coaster with
your songs yes
um so i was going through like a roller
coaster of emotions
just like everyone else and i realized
that
a lot of people were feeling more
anxiety because
they couldn't find the right words to
describe
what they were feeling you know the many
different emotions we were feeling
throughout
2020 um and all the problems in the
world that
everyone was dealing with it's really
hard to put them into words
and because it's so hard to put them
into words um
and we're not able to have a
conversation about it the anxiety builds
so i was trying to in lesson 0
um on the first song of the album
trying to get those words out there
so that people can have a conversation
and also feel like there's somebody else
that understands what they're going
through
another rosario talk about a revenge
song holy smokes buddy
at the video all of it there's a total
you know it's it's a wicked song but i
need to know how
where were you in terms of mentally
writing this song i know you co-wrote
this song
uh was this a fun song or was it it was
it a revenge song
um yeah like i made it in l.a
okay um i started making it in l.a
finished it up when i got back to korea
um so it was it started pre-covered
and then um i finished it up
post like you know during cove yeah so
there's like a crazy amount of emotions
in there
but i i wanted to create a song where
like
we take the anger that we feel um
and try to turn it into some positive
energy
like some kind of uh like empowerment
and that's why i think if you take away
the beats and the wrap
and the hook um it's it's a very
melancholy
sort of somber guitar guitar riff
um but we added the energy in there
because
that's what i felt like everyone was
feeling you know like
not not being able to do anything um
you know being helpless but at the same
time
there's this sense that everybody is
hoping for
the best at the same time like we are
all
hoping for unbelievable amazing changes
to happen
to overcome something that most of us
have never dealt with
and i thought that there was a strength
in that there was a power in that and i
wanted to
put all of that into the song
you know listening to you and talking
about emotions i mean
i here you are creating an album raising
your daughter
how are you coping the fact is we all
needed to be still
we were forced to just be with ourselves
i mean
how are you doing spiritually and
emotionally and physically i guess
uh i think one of the most difficult
things is probably
like all parents will you know
uh relate but virtual school is
not easy it's not yes it's
not easy i think that was one of the
most difficult things
but i am glad for all the people that
are making content
because seriously it really helped us
cope
like yeah um i just spent
the last half an hour watching uh the
new one division episode
with my daughter and just being able to
like
smile and be excited for things every
once in a while
i think um you know we owe a lot to the
people that are create trying to create
some kind of joy that's true it's true
and you know talking about school i mean
i looked back and again you went through
something very
traumatic for you and your family a few
years ago uh
with your you know your credentials your
academic credentials and being tested
and it got me thinking have you been
able to
i guess forgive the situation have you
been able to move on from it or does it
kind of linger with
you um so it's been
almost a decade since yeah um
that happened but i don't think you ever
get over it because my career
and my my freedom i guess i
i i was able to get it back but when i
went through what i went through i also
lost
a lot of things that are completely
irreplaceable
um like your father i understand yes
yes so that's something that i don't
think i ever got over
and every song that i create every album
that i create
i think you mentioned revenge before
um i think this is sort of my way
of slowly getting that sweet revenge
um by creating songs where i deal with
those emotions where i
deal with anger regret
um and just loss and
what i realized that is that the best
revenge
is probably my happiness
so i've been working every single day
since 10 years ago since that happened
and
since i lost my dad so um
it's difficult but i have to keep
working at it because i have a daughter
who deserves
a happy dad do you think part of the
revenge is because of your dad or is it
more because of you
do you feel like you still have to be
defensive to this point because of you
or is it for because of your dad
uh so yeah i spent quite a bit of time
being defensive and sort of never
um being completely free from
uh being a recluse in a way um
i there's a line in my album in the new
album where i say i've been social
distancing
um yeah for the last for the last 10
years and i've been kind of standoffish
um but i feel like
i feel like with this album like working
on this album
there's something that happened inside
of me where i feel
a lot more liberated than i have ever
felt
i think in trying to create songs that
give people a sense of power a sense of
empowerment a sense of
freedom a sense of liberation i think i
unlocked something in my mind as well
because
for some odd reason like after the album
dropped i feel
much much better in that regard yeah
yeah the power of music right um and i'm
glad you're doing better with it and
that you are finding joy i mean your
wife must be one of those people that
brings that joy to you what does she
think of the album did she give you
opinions on certain songs which one's
her favorite
okay so when i first met my wife um
she i don't know how to drive so she was
you don't drive yeah i never learned um
it's just something that escaped me um
so she picked me up in her car on her
first date
and she she had the wu tang album like
the first
wutang album playing in the car
and i knew right away that you know
she was the one so it's all too
tang yes yes so you know she's
like she's listened to a lot of hip-hop
so um when she listens to my music
you know she's just she just like pops
her head
uh and it's like yeah i like this one i
like the bass on this one
and you know that's that's kind of the
kind of feedback i get
you know it's from a hip-hop head so i
love that you're like yeah she likes the
song she loves it
sometimes she'll be like she'll be like
uh
this song i think you should cut like
the track's not
it ain't it um your raps it's weak
and then i'll just cut the trap from
that you're like yo if she doesn't like
it it's over oh my god that's such a
cute story
and your daughter's into billy eilish my
daughter's into billy eilish as well i
mean
oh dark music yes all of them right and
into animals
taking care and rescuing animals same
same thing but
has she been able to kind of help you
through this too i mean
you said you're more with your daughter
has she kind of influenced the music in
this album for you
yeah like definitely um just i think
every child is a genius right um
always curious uh looking for new things
drawn to new things
and just the fact that i have this
little kid who's
into like a lot of music a lot of
visuals and a lot of
art um and you know she's
she's looking at things in a fresh way
so she's introducing me to new
artists every day i never imagined that
i would be listening to
uh billy eilish songs like 12 hours a
day
it's like something and the music's
great
so like her taste and stuff um
is definitely affecting the things i do
and like
this this hat right here with the here
um
it's on the album epic eye is here and
that's her handwriting so she drew this
that's amazing
so she's always a part of my creative
process
i love that
you